souvent les gens plaignent les vieux et
en particulier les vieux homo mais moi
c'est quelque part c'était une des
meilleures périodes de ma vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
les défilés lors de la marche est bon
qu'il a fait parce que ces vagues qui
vous marche des fiertés des plus tôt
jeunesse des finances dans la rue danse
en chantant arriver donc à à 75 ans j'ai
senti le besoin de me reconstruire une
famille à sanitaire pour ne pas qu'on
vivre seul point et souffrir de de cette
solitude
[Musique]
parfois on est obligé de se donner
rendez-vous mais c'est vrai que on est
quand même très très soudés on se
rencontre très très souvent on essaie de
faire que le collectif soit soit
toujours présent c'est à dire que quand
on fait quelque chose que ce soit dans
le domaine de la décoration du ménage de
recevoir des amis des amendes et
sexfriend on en parle avec les autres on
les autres on essaie vraiment une
famille ici l'idée c'est de vivre dans
un appartement comme chez soi et d'avoir
la possibilité en plus de partager avec
d'autres personnes qui sont présentes
dans nos états d'âme nos soirées nourrir
les craintes nos pleurs
[Musique]
globalement si vous voulez l'identité
lgbt a la fâcheuse tendance à
disparaître
lorsqu'on vieillit on ne parle plus
d'identité on parle uniquement du corps
et de la dépendance mais qui que l'on
soit on est plus qu encore on a des
besoins affectifs une sexualité les
besoins intellectuelle donc le fait
qu'on soit qu'on appartienne une rue une
minorité quelle qu'elle soit est un
poids de plus c'est tout
[Musique]
on a besoin de développer des offres à
destination des personnes vieillissantes
à paris à domicile ça c'est vraiment un
besoin exprimé quelles que soient les
catégories de personnes de vieillir de
bien vieillir chez soi
donc il faut qu'on travaille avec ses
bailleurs se sert peut-être des acteurs
privés je ne sais pas en tous les cas il
ya clairement la volonté politique de
notre municipalité d'y travailler et de
mobiliser les moyens pour ce faire
[Musique]